right so now we're going to sort of hit
the accelerator a little bit because I
want you to start working on this a
little more independently
this guy here right y equals four minus
the absolute value of X at this point
here it starts to get a little bit
confusing when you think about all of
the visuals and in fact the algebra is
probably going to help you out a fair
bit here right so what I'm gonna do
straight away is instead of drawing any
stuff on here I'm gonna appeal to my
algebraic definition that I wrote up
above so go ahead drew yourself a set of
axes whilst I'm doing this but let's
think about what this actually means y
equals four minus the absolute value of
X like we said before is shorthand for
two different things number one if X is
positive if that thing inside the
absolute value signs is a positive
number or zero then you just take the
value itself so it's just going to be 4
minus X provided X is greater than or
equal to zero if on the other hand X is
negative then I'm gonna get the other
part of this right so it'll be four take
away negative X 4 take away negative X
is 4 plus X so I'm gonna use these two
as my branches because I know what these
look like I'm 4 minus X is gonna have a
y-intercept at 4 and it's gonna have a
gradient of negative 1 so I'll go ahead
and don't draw that guy in there's 4 and
it's going to have a gradient of
negative 1 so that means I can read off
that x intercept also is 4 and then when
I have a look at the other branch let me
put it in let me switch some colors over
here I'll make this guy here what's
going to complement I'm gonna go with
orange okay
when I have a look at 4 plus X I would
normally write that as X plus 4 it's got
a gradient of 1 but it has that same
y-intercept so it's gonna collide at y
equals 4 up the top there like so so you
can see here I've got x intercept over
here on the left hand side of negative 4
and because I started with my algebraic
definition there's not much work here I
can just label these branches as they
were X plus 4 over here on the left hand
side and then 4 minus X on the right
hand side ok so if you wanted to think
about this visually there's
two changes that happen from our
original absolute value graph for
starters I turned it upside down you
know instead of having this upward
facing V I've got something sort of
facing downward right and that's because
of this minus sign which lives out the
front of the absolute value of X so it
reflects my graph downward and then I
say well this four over here that's
going to be a translation just like
we've been seeing before it's actually a
translation vertically and it's what
smoothly upwards so my intercept is no
longer at the origin right so that's why
you can see them up there at four okay
now I'm going to hand you these last two
examples together and teachers I would
love you - I'm having wander around and
really check and see what's going on
here this idea of absolute value we
don't just apply it to straight lines we
can apply it to any kind of function
particularly when there's a negative of
some kind so for example this is a
parabola that you're that you know how
to graph what happens when we take the
absolute value of that fear what will it
look like what effect will it have this
guy over here on the right the final
example we're going to do together it's
a cubic you've got X cubed there so you
can have to do some factorizing you're
gonna have to you know work out what you
end up with with that quadratic so this
time I'm going to give you what's the
time here so it's 11 23 on my clock
right so what I've done here for these
two graphs is as in the past I've found
it very helpful to have the basic or the
guide graph in my head and then use the
absolute value to make an adjustment
right so what I've got here on the left
hand side y equals x squared minus 1 for
starters I can think about this as a
parabola that has been translated
downward a single unit or I can also
think about it as having those two roots
at negative 1 and 1 and I kind of need
to work out what those are anyway so
that's why I've gone ahead and
factorized have a look for the parts of
the graph that are already positive and
then just leave them there right so in
this case it's over here on the left
hand side that guy can stay exactly
where it is and then you've also got
this guy over here on the right now all
I need to do to complete this graph is
to take that troublesome negative
section right there in the middle
between X is negative 1 and x equals 1
and then reflect it up so I have the
positive sections so looking to me and
my scale
I'm guessing it'll be something like
this OOP there you go I've done bed off
let me try and make it a little more
symmetrical I think I'm making it worse
all right that'll just have to do okay
now obviously I have another y-intercept
there which I need to know remember that
my guide graph it would have had a
y-intercept down here of negative one
because I moved one unit downwards I
translated I should say right so
therefore because I've reflected up that
y-intercept of negative one just becomes
a y-intercept of positive one and we're
good to go
okay I will complete things off by
labeling everything so these parts here
are the concave up sections x squared
minus one and then this guy in the
middle here it's the part that's
reflected it's the negative version
right so this is y equals one minus x
squared which is of course that part of
the parabola that has been number one
flipped upside down and number two
translate it upwards okay
and last one over here the cubic let's
finish it out I will take the same logic
that I used before I do have these
x-intercepts here which I got by
factorization negative two zero and
three here's a positive section of the
graph that I'm just going to do the line
over there we go there's another one
over there on the right hand side for X
is greater than three and then all the
rest of the bits are going to be
reflected up above so that's why you
have this sort of sharp boundary up here
and then the same deal for this guy
which looks kind of like a part of a
moon there so you have this bouncy
weird-looking thing and that's the graph
we're interested in so like before I can
see there's the parts which didn't
change so there's this one here which is
X cubed minus x squared minus 6x which
applies to that little part and also the
part here and then you've got the parts
that I had to reflect these guys and I'm
going to label them with the appropriate
equation which in this case let's just
swap everything around plus x squared
plus 6x there we go so this is most of
what you're going to need to handle for
absolute value graphs in fact we've got
a little bit further in some ways than
some parts of the textbook will go
through yesterday I showed you this and
I crossed off part of it I'm those first
three exercises in the euro
tuna book 3 B 3 C 3 F their to do with
just linear functions and polynomials
for e just that single question question
hey is what will help you have some
practice and actually doing these graphs
and constructing them ok I encourage you
like we did yesterday to have a play
with des moss but for any issues that
you have issue is please go ahead and
let us know if you want to put a
question in the chat or just ask your
teacher now we got a question from Abby
image chat about something going to the
right which graph are you looking at
Abby which one is it there is it the
parabola or is it the cubic which one
are you having trouble with the middle
one ok ah good question
alright so x squared minus 1 isn't it
isn't it going to the right now this is
where if you're looking at this as well
with us that's fine if you're going to
go ahead with your work then teachers if
you want to just go ahead and mute me
that's totally fine I will not take
offense but for anyone who is wondering
why is this graph here why is it not a
horizontal translation I've just done
some up-down stuff ok well you need to
look very carefully at what the equation
looks like here and think about what is
being adjusted again where are those f1
pit stop guys where are they actually
attached to and changing things now it's
a lot harder to see when you've got
these absolute values in the way so
let's just think about the guide graph
for a second I'll do this in I'll do
this in grey because that's how I did my
guy graph if I think about just this
without the absolute values how can I
make clear that there's actually a
vertical translation and there's nothing
happening horizontally well have a look
at that minus one that you can see there
what is it
acting on is it acting on the X and the
answer is even though it's on the right
hand side it's not really because the
thing that's happening to X first is x
squared you can see that kind of
separates it out right so I need to act
directly on the X if I wanted a move to
the right I would have to say X minus 1
and then square ok I know that's a very
very subtle difference but these are two
completely different graphs X minus 1
all squared is actually translated to
the right so when you have a look at
this guy over here what's really
changing that minus 1 or the 1 oh Sh
it belongs on the left-hand side it's
really y plus 1 equals x squared so when
you write it like this you can see that
plus 1 is directly interacting with why
there's no Squared's no square roots no
other stuff in the way so that's why
it's really a vertical change not a
horizontal one so did that answer your
question Abby I hope that's useful it is
a bit tricky I know it's a weird new
ones but hopefully it's a bit clearer
fantastic
all right so teachers I'm going to shut
off my video I will hang around here for
anyone who is actually stuck at home and
they can ask me questions but I'm
assuming that you guys are fine in which
case given there's only a few more
minutes to go I'd love it if you could
indicate to me that you're fine by maybe
switching off maybe logging off I'll
leave the meeting going because I'm
recording for anyone who wants to ask
questions online but thanks you 12 I
hope you guys are having a good day
stay safe don't forget to keep your
distance as much as possible have a good
one
Thanks